é o que está fazendo uma pergunta pra
vocês
quem aqui era um aluno indy a brado
roupa eu era
era daqueles alunos tão peste que
sentava no fundo da casa na vida do
professor de um jeito que o colégio que
ia me expulsar
afinal de contas ser um aluno de abraão
em qualquer colégio tudo bem mas se um
aluno de a brado no colégio militar tem
as suas diferenças
lá eu tinha professores que faziam um
capitão do bope parecia um torrão de
açúcar e aí tinha uma regra que eu
queria passar de ano ea regra era pontos
de participação além das provas que eu
podia fazer eu tinha ponto de
participação se participasse do teatro
da banda do coral e eu resolvi descobrir
qual é a atividade que mais me dava a
ponto de ser da cavalaria me dava dois
pontos de participação é pra lá que eu
vou me disseram que havia no colégio um
centro hípico tudo bem na minha mente
veio belos por o sangue inglês aqueles
obstáculos imponentes
quando eu cheguei lá era uma [ __ ]
havia pouco lama destroço e pouca coisa
lhe lembrava um centro hípico vários
alunos como eu estavam lá esperando as
aulas de equitação mas cavalo não havia
instrutor não havia não havia nada que
eu podia imaginar que aquilo seria uma
condenação uma punição na minha vida mas
eu resolvi encarar aquilo como
oportunidade tijolo por tijolo serrano
madeira pintando obstáculo em questão de
pouco tempo a gente tinha construído em
conjunto um centro hípico e faltavam os
cavalos até que o sargento perguntou
quem queria almoçar com o general
e eu que não tinha medo general
houve almoçar com ele em geral era
alguém que perguntava coisas como quem
venceu a batalha de toró na guerra do
paraguai
eu respondia quando as perguntas deles
terminaram eu resolvi fazer a minha
como é que o senhor acha que alguém vai
se formar em cavalaria nesse colégio a
gente não tem cavalo chegaram 30 em duas
semanas
opa eu comecei a entender que era o
poder de democracia que a gente
realmente aprendi lá no colégio né demo
povo kratos poder
a nota faz uma questão tira total e vai
pra casa mas a democracia é muito mais
do que isso
a democracia é quando a gente tem
participação
não há democracia sem participação
quando terminou o colégio
aquela experiência que tinha sido muito
gostosa não só de construir um centro
hípico de estar junto com os amigos é
equoterapia fazer viagens pelo brasil
inteiro criar torneios competições
fundar um clube de teatro mil coisas
pareciam que iam terminar com a minha
formatura
eu quero fazer isso lá fora ou se uma
rua tem um buraco eu quero thapa de uma
escola pode ser melhorada por que não eu
quero tocar na minha comunidade eu quero
agir politicamente quer que eu tinha
aprendido a fazer lá sem saber que
aquilo se chamava política
me disseram que eu tinha que me filiar a
um partido político e por eliminação eu
escolhi um com o tempo eu descobri que
esse partido político mais parecia um
time de futebol
afinal de contas tudo se dava uma
competição
o meu partido é perfeito e outro partido
não os bate bocas que vinham disso e que
vem disso tomando a nossa internet
transformando as nossas time lines em
coisas insuportáveis fazem com que a
política seja um fla flu
para quem mora lá em minas gerais um
atlético e cruzeiro
bom eu vi que aquilo não ia dar muito
certo
principalmente porque eu notei um fator
fundamental à internet a internet surgiu
para transformar muito a nossa vida
eu dou alguns exemplos eu passei a ser
parte da diretoria do clube atlético
mineiro
o melhor time do brasil lá de minas
gerais onde a gente torce pro atlético e
cruzeiro como deveria ser aqui em juiz
de fora
quando eu passei a fazer parte dessa
diretoria eu encontrei um grande amigo
chamado alexandre kalil
e aí os torcedores eram anunciados pela
rádio porque não presidente criar um
twitter e se comunicar diretamente com a
sua torcida e depois disso as pessoas
não saiam do f5 queremos saber quem era
o próximo jogador olha só a novidade na
campanha do ano passado
todo mundo estava cuidando da internet
what's up - os candidatos
quando eu resolvi pegar o meu e falar
para ele gravar um vídeo para o ats ato
dizendo para as pessoas que as mentiras
que estavam sendo espalhadas podiam ser
conferidos no site
o resultado foi aquele dali foi e vocês
eu também não
então vamos lá chegar
ele achou que era uma coisa difícil de
parar até porque a verdade aparecerá no
sábado 20 pela naturalização está
fazendo um grande momento em que falava
sobre o assunto
lá é o rio azul e vou mostrar que a
mudança chapa no meio do caminho
eu recebi um convite eu estava numa
praia de nudismo jamaica mas isso não
vem ao caso
quando meu telefone tocou o governador
de estado me convidou para ser
secretário de juventude
lá fui eu virei secretário de juventude
e no cargo o meu partido começou a me
cobrar cargos
você precisa na minha pessoa tal pessoa
a pessoa a pessoa a pessoa a pessoa
um ninho de tucanos queria fazer parte
do governo e eu fui dizendo não não não
não não
a situação ficou insustentável porque
era muito difícil explicar o meu partido
que uma legenda é um grupo e um governo
é feito para todos e aparelhamento é uma
coisa condenável
só que isso é muito simples de discursar
e dificílimo de colocar em prática
eu tava com uma encruzilhada ou meu
partido ou governo e eu mandei o meu
partido para um lugar que vocês conhecem
muito bem e mandam aquelas pessoas que
vocês têm grande desapreço eu me tornei
alguém sem partido
eu não tinha mais uma legenda e comecei
a me questionar como era possível fazer
política sem estar filiado e comecei a
entrar nessa rota
e olha essa idéia de 100 partida boa
comecei a pesquisar pesquisar pesquisar
quando de repente lá em 2013
quatro meses depois vou me desfiliar as
ruas do país começaram a se encher e
quem inventasse de entrar uma
manifestação com uma bandeira de partido
era completamente fustigado e eu achei
fabuloso
olha só o brasil está notando que é
possível fazer política sem partido
bem eu não sabia que essa experiência ea
ser tão próxima à linha paleta
bastou uma conta pra mim e falar aquele
de polir
olha o resultado
meus amigos mais íntimos
a vontade não gostaram do trigo que é o
padrinho
tudo que eu dizia eu concordo com vocês
estão ocorrendo essa manifestação é
muito importante alguém dava melódico
político ladrão partilhado o câmbio da
china
sai daqui se eu tivesse jogado uma pedra
bastava para montar aqui hoje com vocês
isso não aconteceu mas isso só me
motivou
porque esse é o tipo de cena que eu
convido vocês todos a se imaginar em
nela haja coragem como tcheco falava
essa é a virtude fundamental sem ela
todas as outras despenca
comecei a pesquisar mais ainda é
possível fazer política sem partido
afinal de contas quando é que surgem os
partidos porque eu precisava entender
isso para hackear política e aí eu conto
pra vocês que partido político surgiu lá
em 1832 como a inglaterra fez uma
reforma que botou muita gente para votar
com muita gente votando
precisamos de estratégias para fazer as
pessoas votarem em determinados
candidatos
surge a figura do militante do burocrata
partidário do empreendedor eleitoral a
mesma máquina que funciona até hoje isso
na inglaterra
já os estados unidos como a principal
disputa ao invés de um parlamento era de
um presidente que tinha como livre
nomeação 400 mil cargos a coisa atinge
um nível gigantesco porque era tão caro
tão caro que começaram a surgir figuras
chamadas boss especialistas em captar
dinheiro para financiar a campanha
eleitoral
você já deve ter visto alguma figura
para viver com essa e ainda teve o caso
da alemanha na alemanha como tinha uma
campanha grande nem um parlamento forte
possibilitou sua existência de partidos
ideológicos sociais-democratas
comunistas liberais com defeito de
fábrica
toda vez que eles assumiram o poder a
ideologia se dissipava três modelos de
partido que foram batidos no
liquidificador
e vieram para o brasil mas vieram com
100 anos de atraso em relação ao século
19 porque enquanto eles já estavam
evoluindo assim na europa e nos estados
unidos
por aqui a gente ainda o império e havia
dois times de futebol ou dois partidos o
liberal e conservador
a disputa quem gostava mais do imperador
e o povo não participava
depois o império caiu e veio república
aí os times foram regionais partido
republicano mineiro partido republicano
paulista partido republicano gaúcho cada
um no seu quintal sendo que os dois mais
fortes dividiram a presidência ao longo
de vários anos tomando uma xícara de
café com leite
aí vem um gaúcho que amarrou os cavalos
no rio de janeiro e com o estado novo
dissolveu essa história de partido
durante 37 a 45 não teve partido no
brasil e só em 46 no finalzinho de 45
com a nova constituinte que os partidos
puderam assistir no brasil
dessa vez as eleições e eu contar com o
povo e aquela tecnologia de 100 anos
atrás da inglaterra e é implementada
aqui todos os partidos surgiram junto
com a figura de getúlio vargas ptb o
partido do getúlio psd o partido que
dava apoio getúlio o dn o partido que
era contrário e ficamos nisso até 64
quando o ato institucional número 2
acabou com aquela quantidade de partidos
e criou dois
a arena de quem era a favor da ditadura
e o mdb movimento democrático brasileiro
que ainda não tinham p e portanto
abrigava todos aqueles que queriam
combater a ditadura veio a
redemocratização e os partidos como
conhecemos hoje começaram a surgir pmdb
ptb e pdt e pt têm pc do b psb e pv vai
rolar e ouvir um narrador de cavalo para
amarrar todos que estão aqui
trinta e cinco partidos 123 informação
com o fundo partidário e tempo de
televisão
sem falar na questão da população
eu digo pra vocês que apesar disso tudo
hoje exatamente quando eu tava vindo pra
cá eu lia mais recente datafolha que
mostrou que 71% da população não se
identifica com nenhum deles e 3 por
cento menos do que isso confia neles
ora qual é o problema a nossa
constituição no seu artigo 14 parágrafo
3º inciso 5º exige a filiação partidária
como condição de elegibilidade
quantas pessoas no brasil são filiadas
7% 93% do brasil está fora do jogo
pensem nisso o brasil compõe um grupo
restrito de menos de 10% do país do
mundo que o partido exigido como
necessidade para ser candidato
nos estados unidos não na inglaterra não
na alemanha não em vários outros não a
uma ilha na oceania chamada louis onde
os partidos já não existem desde 2005 e
é por isso que a democracia deixou de
existir lá não porque afinal de contas
ela já existia antes dos partidos os
partidos gente funcionam como o primeiro
organograma que vocês vêem ele
centralizado
sempre há alguém que manda e outros
pontos que obedecem
desconheço partido com democracia
interna
alguns que podem parecer mais com o
segundo gráfico com regionalidades sendo
que a nossa sociedade se comporta como
terceiro modelo uma sociedade em rede
como portanto aplicar esse modelo
naquele modelo que vocês conhecem tão
bem no facebook
what's up e no cotidiano a minha
proposta que aliás já existe uma
proposta de emenda à constituição pec
não se trata de cláusula pétrea a gente
pode risca o inciso 5º e deixar de
exigir a fidelidade à a filiação a
partido
como condição de elegibilidade já isso
no senado já na câmara
muitas assinaturas mas não vai pra
frente eu tive só esse ano e inúmeras
tentativas conversando com gente do tee
do pmdb veja o meu esforço do psdb e do
pt para tentar convencê los dessa idéia
mas eles são relutantes porque não há
política sem partido dizem para mim que
nós vamos enfraquecer os partidos que
podem criaturas eu imagino partido como
o mico-leão-dourado com aquele fundo
partidário gigantesco e com horas e
horas de televisão são figuras frágeis
são partidos que são frágeis os
comportamentos deles nada ideológicos
que fragilizam a nossa crença nessas
instituições
segundo eles me dizem que seria terrível
de candidatos independentes porque nós
temos anomalias artistas lutadores
esportistas não se candidatar claro
final o atual modelo proíbe esse tipo de
figura seja candidato a favor eu digo o
seguinte pra vocês
basta de oligopólio partidária imaginem
um cenário onde todo mundo pudesse ser
candidato
o jogo ia mudar porque os agentes vão
mudar
a universidade federal de juiz de fora
poderia se unir para lançar um candidato
que defendesse os interesses da
universidade ou um bairro uma associação
sem que o partido fosse um portão quem
pedisse essa participação e os partidos
não precisam deixar de existir
quem quiser continua se filiando a eles
que para ser candidato independente não
basta a vontade pessoal
na maioria dos lugares onde existe você
tem que colher assinaturas bom
lamentavelmente essa pec não passou nas
discussões da reforma política de 2014
vocês bem acompanharam pouquíssimas
foram as evoluções
eu diria que a gente inclusive involuiu
em vários aspectos e o partido segue
como opção com a minha proposta pra
gente hackear o sistema lembra do mdb
que abrigava todo mundo
o pmdb é um partido ônibus
quer dizer para todos como
veículo que a gente conhece encontra em
um partido que tope abrigar vocês assim
uma causa de independência dizer que
vocês não têm nada a ver com esse
partido só tá usando aquela legenda
porque é uma obrigação o seu compromisso
vai ser com o seu ideal com as pessoas
com o coletivo e sobretudo com as idéias
que valem a pena ser espalhadas
acreditem se a gente hackear política e
considerar o partido não rio
intransponível
mais uma canoa para transpor esse
desafio
nós vamos despertar o poder da
democracia que há em cada um de nós muda
cidade do estado rumo do país e mudou o
mundo
muito obrigado